salut aujourd'hui le concept c'est que
je vais débattre de n'importe quel sujet
avec les personnes qui veulent débattre
avec moi mais il travaillent pour manger
il cultiv leur terre oui mais pour
donner au roi ah bah c'est vrai que le
roi il prenait c'est un important
vecteur de maladie humaine Fabien c'est
mais ça c'est ce qu' vous font croire
tous les êtres humains localement
dominés par des chats je vous ai pas
précisé mais les débats ils ont été pris
sur Instagram on vous avait demandé et
surtout les personnes qui viennent
débattre avec moi elles m'imposent ma
position d'être pour ou d'être contre
quelque chose ah non mais la vie était
plus simple au Moyen-Âge ça et oui donc
en fait le chat peut dominer l' mais pas
le monde on parle pas des toilettes
turques qui n'ont pas de cuvett on parle
pas des toilettes sèches sur cabanon je
résume ils arrivent avec un sujet de
débat que je ne connais pas il m'impose
la position dans ce débat moi j'ai pas
d'argument donc je vais faire preuve
d'ultra crépidarianisme ça veut dire
faire une TPMP tu débats sur un truc
mais tu connais rien au
sujet les chats vont dominer le monde
moi je veux que Fabien soit pour et moi
bien sûr je suis contre pour le fait que
ce soit possible c'est ça pour le fait
que ce soit possible tout à fait on a vu
déjà par le passé que les chats était
considéré par comme des divinités par
les Pharaons est-ce que c'est un hasard
je pense pas je pense que justement
l'Égypte antique nous a apporté un
certain nombre de savoir et c'est pas
pour rien qu'elle a divinisé les chats
parce qu'elle semble méfié en réalité
genre je me permets quand même
d'intervenir c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont été
divinisé par qui par l'homme
effectivement parce que le chat sans
l'homme n'est qu'un petit animal sur
quatre pattes vulnérable oui mais
fragile et vous Virginie kaloun vous
obéissez au chat à tous les ordres qui
qui vous donne est-ce que vous avez déjà
eu un chat dans votre vie j'ai déjà
gardé un chat vous avez gardé un chat ou
est-ce que vous avez refusé de le
nourrir quand il avait faim non est-ce
que vous avez refusé de le caresser
quand il s'approchait de vous non est-ce
que vous avez refusé qu'il s'assiait sur
vous quand lui le décide al moi mon
sujet c'est que la vie était plus
difficile au Moyen-Âge ça semble assez
logique c'était plus difficile mais je
vais demander à Fabien d'être contre ça
la vie contraire la vie était plus
simple au Moyen-Âge ah non mais la vie
était plus simple au Moyen-Âge comment
ça la vie était plus simple au Moyen Âge
tout était plus facile en fait par
exemple facture EDF tu as vu
l'augmentation là ces derniers temps oui
effec tu avais pas ça non il y avait pas
ça mais av tu avais pas de paperace à
faire en permanence toute la paperace
qu'on fait aujourd'hui tu avais pas ça
tu avais pas à faire de planans sur la
retraite tu mourais vers 32 ans donc
impeccable un cheveu blanc c'était la
vieillesse tu savais que tu allais
partir tu avais pas t'occuper de ça non
c'était plus simple d' de manière
générale ou mais par exemple tu dis
qu'il y avait pas de factureedf
effectivement mais c'est parce qu'il y
avait pas d'électricité mais est-ce que
c'est une bonne chose qu'on ait
l'électricité aujourd'hui avec toute la
pollution que ça a engendré est-ce que
si tu regardes l'air moderne ok on a eu
de la facilité du confort de vie on
détruit notre planète à cause de ça
est-ce qu'on était pas plus connecté à
notre nature au Moyen-Âge dans le fond
moi je pense que si faut-il baisser ou
laisser lever la cuvette des toilettes
je suis évidemment pour la baisser et
Fabien contre toute attente et pour
laisser lever la cuvette des toilettes
ça me paraît évident excuse-moi je je
commence le débat je vais appuyer sur
desmar mais ça me paraît évident qu'il
faille la laisser je suis même très
étonné qu'une personne aussi
consciencieuse que toi faisant preuve
d'hygiène parce qu'en général je trouve
que tu ne sens pas
mauvais c'est une forme de compliment
dans le fond trè é que tu veux la
laisser baisser mais bon petit he alors
pr dans une réponse c'est un important
vecteur de maladie humaine Fabien ah ça
je suis bien d'accord intéressant donc
excuse-moi mais comment tu tu nettoies
et comment tu contrôles visuellement
quand toi tu arrives que les toilettes
sont propres si quelqu'un a rabattu en
fait la lunette des toilettes pour
cacher ses méfits et crois-moi que rien
dans ces bureaux je veux vraiment pas
dire du mal de loï mais quand même
comment tu veux qu'on s'en sorte pour
voir si ça a bien été nettoyé si c'est
baissé je pense que ça permet quand même
d'avoir un petit temps d'adaptation
quand tu rentres les toilettes de ne pas
être waouh choqué par ce qui s'est passé
précédemment donc toi tu préfères un
espèce de d'aquarium à bactéries un truc
qu'on referme comme ça ça fermente bien
et quand toi tu vas te mettre dessus ça
va attaquer tes muqueuses excuse-moi de
prendre soin de toi je préfère toujours
ça plutôt que ça m'attaque dès que
j'ouvre la porte des toilettes
excusez-moi j'interromb B 2 secondes
pour vous parler du partenaire du jour
l'application haridle l'application j'ai
pu la tester c'est de l'Escape game en
réalité augmenté c'est très bluffant
c'est une innovation mondiale c'est même
assez dur à vous expliquer en fait j'ai
adoré faire ça l'appli elle est
disponible sur téléphone sur tablette
c'est un peu une sorte de Netflix des
jeux en réalité augmenté pour le moment
ils ont 5 escape GAM en réalité
augmentés mais ils vont étoffer en plus
l'application avec des puzzle box avec
des jeux de basket même un jeu de foot
si vous êtes un peu geek vous connaissez
peut-être bvatek 2023 ils avaient gagné
un challenge innovation là-bas quand je
l'ai testé j'étais dans le bureau déjà
c'était fou parce que tu appuies et il y
a une porte dimensionnelle qui se met en
réalité augmenté qui est hyper stable ça
aussi c'est très bluffant et le plus
bluffant c'est que tu joues en
multioueur donc tu as l'avatar de
l'autre personne qui est à l'autre bout
du monde pourquoi pas et la personne
avec qui je l'ai testé c'était fou on
s'entendait par l'application et je la
voyais dans ses déplacement elle me
voyait en retour pour moi c'est ça
c'était jamais vu ça fait partie des
trucs qui m'ont vraiment bluffé
évidemment je vous mettrai un lien dans
la description et ce que j'aime bien
c'est qu'il y a pas besoin de casque VR
de matériel spécifique on télécharge
l'application c'est bon on peut jouer en
fait j'ai testé le jeu avec l'un des
créateurs ce qui nous a permis de de
beaucoup échanger et il y a quelque
chose qui m'a particulièrement touché je
prends un tout petit peu de temps pour
vous le partager si vous prenez les jeux
de la série retrouver la coupe sur
haridle vous faites une très bonne
action la moitié des revenus réalisés
sont directement reversés à
d'association à maillot pour la vie qui
aide des enfants hospitalisés et ça va
plus loin que ça c'est-à-dire que ces
escape games de cette série- là ils sont
disponibles gratuitement pour les
enfants dans les hôpitaux ils ont pas à
l'acheter ils ont tout qui débloqué ils
peuvent y jouer directement donc depuis
leur lit malgré ce qu'ils vivent ils
peuvent se téléporter et retrouver même
leurs amis ou leur famille près de des
pyramides égyptiennes ou dans une usine
de chocolat parce que on peut y jouer
debout mais on peut aussi jouer en mode
ass si vous voulez découvrir des escabim
en réalité augmenter vraiment bluffant
vraiment très fun je vous invite à
télécharger à ridle le lien est dans la
description et puis peut-être qu'on se
croisera dessus c'est pas impossible non
mais en parle d'un chat vous faites
dominer vous vous faites dominer en fait
en réalité écoutez oui je me fais
dominer dans la mesure de mes limites
c'est-à-dire que je pose des limites à
partir du moment où je domine encore
malgré tout ma vie mon quotidien ma ma
structure mais mais parce que les chates
sont malins ils ont tout le temps devant
eux ils commencent par vous dominer vous
et puis à un moment donné si il miaent à
la porte pendant 10 minutes vous allez
vous lever et lui ouvrir même si vous
êtes fatigué ou vous allez le laisser
mioler et attendre non je vais lui
ouvrir qui a la liberté c'est le chat
qui a la liberté et qui domine son être
humain en attendant de se mettre
d'accord évidemment avec les autres
chats du quartier parce qu'on les entend
se répondent quand même quand il miolent
le jour où ils prendront le pouvoir ils
nous obligeront tous en même temps à
faire les mêmes actions et ce jour-là
qu'est-ce qu'on
fera que vous ferez vous direz ah ben
j'ai pas le choix parce que c'est que
moi de localement qui suis dominé mais
tous les êtres humains localement
dominés par des chats ça donne les chats
qui contrôle le monde oui alors par
exemple peut-être mais tout ce qui était
maladie santé à l'époque on avait pas
non on avait pas la médecine
d'aujourd'hui oui aujourd'hui on peut
diagnostiquer traiter à l'époque déjà
pas besoin de cte vital non c'est vrai
pas de mise à jour dans les pharmacies
ce genre de choses un traitement qui
sone tout la saigner donc on faisait
saigner le sang et et et c'est bon tu
avais ton traitement non mais d'accord
mais sauf que on ne soignait pas mais
c'est pas le problème le problème c'est
est-ce que c'était plus simple ou pas
c'était plus simple parce que tu savais
qu' quelle allait être ton traitement
cétait beaucoup plus rapide à
diagnostiquer on disait on te regardait
on disait
sa c'est quoi les symptômes c'est pas
grave les symptômes symptôes ça crée de
l'emploi la cuvette des toilettes il est
important de la laisser fermer pour
qu'on montre le travail de ces designers
qui confectionnent ces toilettes et
toutes ces personnes qui prennent le
temps de les acheter et je pense que la
laisser ouverte c'est un peu ne pas
rendre hommage à tous ces emplois donc
vous vous voulez juste qu'on privilégie
les emplois qui font le dessus de la
cuvette et pas le dessous parce qu'à
priori une fois qu'elle est levée on
s'assiet ouais donc en fait on ne verra
jamais l'autre partie du travail c'est
bien pour ça qu' al comme ma proposition
consistait effectivement vous avez
raison en terme d'hygiène à ce qu'on
baisse la lunette pour tirer la chasse
d'eau pendant ce temps-là on apprécie et
on découvre en plus donc y a de la la
surprise notre attention est captée tous
nos sens cognitifs sont en éveil et une
fois que la chasse Doig a fait son effet
on peut relever et laisser tel un
tableau effectivement face à soi dans la
pièce et pas qu'on regarderit comme ça
par dessus la lunette des toilettes oui
mais vous avouerez quand même que si un
chat devit définir voà si devait oui
c'est très très
spéculatif non c'est juste parce que moi
je vous apporte des faits en fait des
détails est-ce qu'on a déjà trouvé un
animal capable de défquer dans notre
maison en attendant que nous nettoyions
ces toilettes vous accepteriez ça de
quel animal même si un chien faisait ça
défqué dans votre maison vous fâcheriez
le chien en fait vous le puniriez pour
qu'il ne recommence pas les chats on est
là oh ben merci oh ben tu as fait des
cacades et puis P je vais tout ramasser
puis je vais dépenser une fortune pour
te remettre une litière qui te convienne
que tu feras exprès de gratter en dehors
mais je nettoiré parce que le pauvre il
a pas fait exprès mais mais vous êtes
naïve évidemment qu'ils font exprès ils
testent notre ristance oui donc en fait
le chapeu dominé mais l'homme est pas le
monde parce que concrètement le monde il
c'est que c'est un animal qui est
solitaire le monde est un animal
solitaire le chat est un animal
solitaire qui n'est pas capable de faire
des stratégies des coalitions il pense
beaucoup à son petit nombril c'està dire
qu'il serait incapable de maintenir une
socié chat non ça fait pas de stratégies
coalition de coalition entre chats ils
sont pas en groupe ils sont pas cap pas
comme les fourmis par exemple ou pas
comme les singes mais c'est mais ça
c'est ce qui vous font croire mais alors
peut-être que c'était plus simple dans
le fait il y avait des choses plus
simples à faire mais au niau niveau de
la vie de tous les jours pour les gens
les citoyens comment on appelait ça
avant les les pelos
les les les les le peuple untit peu le
peuple c'était pas facileêtre un
aristoage par contre parce que ils
avaient ils avaient pas du coup pas
d'accès à la santé il ils avaient pas de
congé payé hein c'est-à-dire qu'il
travaillaient tout le temps mais ils
travaillaient pour manger ils
cultivaient leur terre oui mais pour
donner au roi ah bah c'est vrai que le
roi il prenait ah bah ah ben alors
excusez celui qui défend son peuple
prendre 90 % de ses ressources hein hein
et puis ils avaient mais ça ça c'était
plus simple parce que je je maintiens
que tu m'as mis dans la position de
trouver ça plus simple et ben c'était
quand même plus simple que de faire tes
feuilles d'impôt tu savais qu'on allait
prendre 90 % de ce que tu avais point le
matin tu avais pas de réveil matin qui
t'extipait du lit tu avais les coqu bah
voilà et puis aussi ton cycle du sommeil
naturel hein de toute manière comme tu
avais pas mangé la veille la fin
réveillé donc beaucoup plus simple quand
même de sortir du lit pas de patron pas
de choses comme ça non c'était plus
simple dans principe de la simplicité tu
savais à peu près de quoi all être fait
demain j'aurais d dire moins bien aller
aux toilettes sa forme de symbolique et
quand on arrive on a envie d'ouvrir une
nouvelle histoire d'écrire son chapitre
et de refermer à tout jamais cette
histoire et de la laisser dans le passé
et c'est un peu la métaphore des
toilettes je vous trouve quand même je
je trouve que vous faites preuve de
beaucoup de discrimination voilà si je
peux me permettre je suite grand mots on
parle pas des toilettes turques qui
n'ont pas de cuvette on parle pas des
toilettes sèchees sur cabanon qui en
général n'ont pas de cuvette en général
et je je je pense qu'aujourd'hui vu la
situation écologique du monde on devrait
plutôt se concentrer sur cette manière
plutôt que sur quelque chose que je
considère un peu être du bobo
parisianisme de mon œuvre d'art sur mes
toilettes est-ce que je la lève est-ce
que je la baisse excusez-moi mais je
pense qu'on est audessus de tout ça
quand même les chats qui ont pénétré le
domicile des hommes pour commencer le
travail évidemment qu' sont seuls s'il y
a qu'un seul chat regarder dans la
nature regarder les chats dans la nature
nature comment ils interagissent entre
eux en réalité ils font preuve de
stratégie ils font preuve de
regroupement ils font preuve de l'esprit
de meut ce sont des félins quand même
ils ont l'esprit de meut bien sûr
évidemment
ouais je vous sens pas sûr de vous là si
c'est là où ils sont plus forts que nous
c'est que pour vous coalition c'est quoi
c'est faire des réunions on s'envoie des
mails on se voit on en discute on en
débat eu ils ont pas de réunion à faire
ils savent le but final dominer le monde
et le monde actuel il est dominé par qui
par les hommes dominer les hommes c'est
dominer le monde j'ai plus rien à dire
ne pleurez pas on va mettre débart mais
à l'époque les femmes la condition des
femmes oui c'était c'était pas facile
parce que elle mourrait en couche parce
qu'il y avait pas justement la médecine
donc BIM un enfant tu sais pas même
l'enfant tu sais même pas s'il va VI
jours ou pas pour moi c'est pas un
argument recevable tu dis qu'elle mourit
en couche j'ai jamais vu des
lithographies de femmes avec des couches
dans les livres qui traitent du
Moyen-Âge ouais donc je veux bien
discuter avec toi mais les arguments
fallacieux non
merci là vraiment je suis forcée
d'admettre que que que bah oui que je
lui donne C je lui donne 5 je crois
vraiment que les chats peuvent dominer
le monde
maintenant Fabien m'a laissé un petit
peu sans voie avec ce dernier argument
puisque je me suis vu entraîner à parler
de minorité pour les toilettes turques
et je n'avais pas envie d'aborder un
quelconque sujet par rapport à ça donc
en vrai bravo Fabi bien parce que tu as
un peu retourné le truc de manière à ce
qu'on sache plus vraiment c'était quoi
le débat initial et du coup je sais plus
si je suis convaincu ou pas donc je
pense je mettrai quatre j'ai bien été
convaincu alors j'avoue que là je
pensais arriver avec un truc facile
effectivement ça me semblait c'estz
logique au Moyen-Âge c'était bah c'était
moins bien alors je vois comment il a
fait même moi à la fin j'étais convaincu
je dirais même j'ai envie peut-être de
vivre au Moyen-Âge peut-être revenir non
peut bon en tout cas voilà il m'a
convaincu je donne 4 et demi parce que
c'est vrai que sur la les femmes qui
accouché en couche tout ça on a senti
qu'il a il a voulu mettre une petite une
petite disquette comme ça mais sinon il
m'a ouais je ouais là où il y a pas de
débat c'est sur l'application ridle
vraiment tester au moins une fois l'un
de ces escape GAM en réalité augmenté
j'ai testé c'est hallucinant c'est une
innovation mondiale et avec la série
retrouver la coupe vous faites en même
temps une bonne action puisque la moitié
des revenus vont à l'association à
maillot pour la vie qui aide les enfants
hospitalisés donc merci à eux de m'avoir
contacté pour que j'en parle dans la
vidéo je m'appelle toujours fabianola à
très bientôt Ciao